hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
hail pen show joining me on the show
today is the co-host of the number one
men's podcast in the world fresh and fit
he's a master networker and he's
somebody who's tapped into everything
and everyone in Miami and you may see
him rolling around Miami in his green
hurricane Evo fresh welcome to the show
how are you that was a great intro man I
love that I was stressed about it I'm
not gonna lie I was thinking I might
need to do this three times but I nailed
that 10 out of 10 let's go thank you how
are you pretty good it's a Friday in
Miami can't complain good weather good
food good people love it yeah it's great
to have you here thank you so much for
coming on so we had Myron on a few weeks
ago and I got his side of everything and
how you know fresh and fit started
because I have to say I think you guys
have just revolutionized content
completely you've become like the gold
standard of content Creation in my
opinion
um there we go yeah cough cough coffee
cats so um I'd love to hear your side of
the story um how did everything start
actually how did you and Myron meet how
did fresh and fit come about
so to go back in time it's funny because
back then I was so focused on being a
YouTuber being successful I did prank
videos I did like Vlogs I did whatever I
could to make content to try to blow up
you know and then I figured out a way to
go viral online by using certain methods
and I did three major videos of gold
digger pranks you know what those are
all right no gold digger pranks yes I do
yeah yeah so when you get a Lambo you
either rent it or use your friends Rambo
girls pass by you say hey you want to
get a ride and say no at the beginning
because it's a regular car you pull up
with the lambo I want to get it now long
story short I did three of those videos
that blew up on Worldstar went crazy wow
I got a little buzzing in Miami and then
I did interview with a friend of mine
solo tv84 he brought me on top of my
lifestyle I was doing Instagram and then
he said I got a friend of mine in Miami
as well he's chilling with him which is
Myron Gaines so he's doing Fitness
videos back then I was doing prank
videos been linked up for dinner tough
like an hour similar interests real
estate girls dating all that stuff and
you say you know what let's do our own
show and before you know it we did a
virtual show I was at my house it was
like his crib as well and then people
liked it we get some good sauce some
good game some good like dating advice
people loved it we did once a week twice
a week and then from there was history
getting a studio that's crazy I actually
didn't know that you did those gold
digger videos I've definitely seen them
then because I remember years ago seeing
it and thinking it was so funny so
that's incredible that it's you they're
kind of cringe but hey that's
the past right yeah well no I mean
that's how you have to blow up with
social media I mean I I look at some of
my content I'm like oh that's cringe but
it's what it is but um yeah I was saying
you know in the intro that you're just
so tapped into everything going on in
Miami I see you on Instagram that you
know you're at this show that place
you're here you're there so how are you
so tapped into everything that's a
secret my friend no you got to tell us
so so uh I think network is important
because most people they go through life
and they think they can do it by
themselves they're Lone Wolf and I think
that's on sun level good but not the
best because on some level you need a
team and I think personally speaking me
I just saw in Miami is all about who you
know and who knows you so very quickly I
was like you know what how can I meet
people have a certain status certain
level and me myself was kind of broke
back then I was working at Chick-fil-A
you know making calls ATT kind of like a
low level type of like entry because I
just came to America but I knew I want
to be successful from where you said you
just came in Barbados from Barbados yeah
so that's like seven years ago so then I
was okay cool people that I see in the
streets writing Lambos living lifestyle
all these people how to get there so one
day was a Starbucks studying about like
you know success and you know mindset
and I saw a guy pull up in a Lamborghini
with a white chick I'm like damn this
needs to be me
hey man I don't know what it is
so ask him hey bro uh not sorry to
bother you what do you do for a living
should I do real estate I invest my
money into real estate I want to Major
assets I get cash flow I live like what
I want to I was like really she's done
making buy real estate invest into it
and then like live how I want to awesome
so from that day on instead of real
estate YouTube Bigger Pockets different
podcasts and I got the insight for like
real estate but I was okay I don't know
anybody here in Miami
how to meet people someone online to
meetup.com looked at different real
estate events real estate uh activities
went to those then I realized whatever I
want to learn I can go to the activities
and events meet people in that same
space the same environment so I did that
for business did that for you know
investing and real estate as well and
over time I created like a whole like
community of people that I knew from
going out from different events and what
happened was be in those circles I
learned I'm not I'm gonna know
everything myself but they might know
something I don't know just information
I would say I want to say do you have
information back and forth like that at
least are you learning more for yourself
and as well getting a bigger knowledge
so I think having a network of people
like are better than you or either on
the same path gives you more success
that's what I would say that's so
interesting because um that's such a
good mindset there are so many people
that you know come to this country and
they complain and you know people who
are born here and they still complain
and they're still broke but you said you
came here seven years ago and you're
broke and now you have a Lambo wait oh
no sorry I have a haircut anyway you
know scary though like being in that
environment yeah working the phone call
center the call center I was talking
with our 40 years old 50 years old still
doing the same job right here so I'm
like this is scary to me because like
you've been in your whole life and
you're still working the same job that
scariest me so just like I didn't want
to be that person and I knew coming here
either I make it or I don't there's no
way back so that was it that's like the
epitome of the American dream yeah and
everyone says that it's dead but clearly
it's not yeah definitely yeah yeah
that's amazing that's so fascinating to
me and throughout that Journey because I
know you said you know you did the gold
digger pranks you were um you know
working at Chick-fil-A you were doing
just like multiple things what was your
most successful Venture before fresh and
fit so I will say this uh working at a
job with my bustle successful right here
because back then I didn't know how to
like I guess monetize or kind of like
actually get traction on different side
businesses so I knew having a job like
would keep me stable but luckily for me
this job actually gave me unlimited
overtime so people don't know this but
like
at that job I could work from like 6 a.m
to 12 midnight seven six no six days a
week because you can't wear seven days
in a row that's legal but okay six days
a week I can work from like six a.m in
the morning or 5 a.m like 12 midnight um
so I did that for two years basically
and I didn't take any breaks my friends
would say hey let's go drink a beer
let's go out I was like nah bro I want
to focus to get my money up first
because I was broke and you're not a
time period I'll look at YouTube videos
about you know once again real estate
investing so we'll learn while I was
working this job however I realized as
well being this consistent at a job I
was not getting into where I wanted to
be but I was saving money but in an
interim like I said earlier I was
learning about how to invest so the time
I took to do this job was maybe a
success because back then I could
actually focus on doing one thing we'll
learn at the same time
but I just think that mindset is so it's
so um commendable because
um a lot of men and I know you talk
about so on your podcast you know
everyone's a victim nobody wants to do
this so how how do you inspire other
people to take responsibility of their
lives and just basically do what you did
you know you saw somebody with a nice
car and a white girl and you're like I
want that so how do you inspire other
men to do that I actually think that you
need to find a way or why you want to do
it because I can tell you all day yeah
go be successful go be the man of Honor
about amount of value but if you don't
want it what's the point so you have to
understand why you want it either for
family yourself for girls maybe for like
just to have money not to be broke
whatever that is figure out why you want
to do it and then go from there but I'll
say this I saw was possible seeing it
face to face so I'm from Barbados so
back back there there's no like
Lamborghinis no like Ferrari is this
like Toyota Corolla you might say
Mitsubishi Evo beautiful women though no
yeah beautiful women yeah that's where
Rihanna's from yeah we went to Sam
school by the way did you hilarious oh
wow she's very beautiful yeah she is
um but you know back then I couldn't see
what success was or sample what I
thought was possible so just seeing it
in real life touching it like I tell
people all the time you want a
Lamborghini you want a lifestyle go sit
in one touch it feel it actually feel
the power of manifesting because I think
if you can manifest it and you really
want it you'll play actions towards
those like uh thoughts and the actions
will lead to habits this leads to the
lifestyle which leads to success so I
think personally speaking is one of a
successful lifestyle touch it feel it be
around it okay it's possible if he can
do it why can't I do it the law of
proximity there you go and I love that
um and my brother and I we feel the same
way because you know we come from
England and you know I mean that awesome
nice places in London for sure but like
you don't really see Lambos you know and
the other day I just left my apartment
and there's just like a Lambo just there
in front of me and I'm not I'm not like
money crazy like men are but like it's
not bad to wake up and see a Lambo in
your front you know right where you live
it's nice you know what it is it's more
like it's possible and yeah for example
me myself like my goal was always having
nice cars but the lambo means for me
okay I saw a vision I saw something I
want to achieve and I achieved it and of
course I love cars as well but it's more
like having that in my mind from five
years ago like okay I'm starting from
the bottom but eventually I'll get there
so now I feel like I can do anything
because I achieved it and it could be
either a house it could be for example a
status of financial status whatever it
is whatever it is to you if you achieve
it I guarantee you from there on out you
could you feel like you're like
invincible and do you think was fresh
and fit as successful as you thought it
would be or did you or did you have no
idea that this show was gonna just blow
up as it has rough you will not believe
this right I'm thinking to myself okay
cool we're just gonna talk to guys about
dating yeah a little fun here and there
but anything that big but what happened
was is we saw people had a need for it
and with that need they started to share
with their friends their family uncles
cousins Brothers even girlfriends I'm
like damn this is actually going viral
and then mine did a video talking about
we should punish women for bad behavior
the classic knows about and Tick Tock
was going crazy at that time so it was
like oh wow so that went viral we end up
on newspapers news stations like
different TV shows I'm like damn now
we're hitting Limelight but that rise to
like I guess like I want to say
semi-fame just show me that okay cool
how can we make this I I already think
so I went behind the scenes as well did
some stuff I saw that could be done for
my prior experience for for example
networking meetings at yellows companies
okay how to go viral on YouTube and over
time you just kept building up on that
and then Myron's talking his talking
points and it went boom but we had no
idea it was gonna be like that at all no
idea at all how's your relationship with
women changed as fresh and fit has
become more successful oh okay so I
actually love women I love I'm sure
they're all women I love being in their
environment I just love the feminine
energy however I'll say this
I had no idea girls didn't well I want
to say care about men's plights I
thought maybe they might have a Little
Bit of Sympathy a little bit empathy but
they really don't have much I would say
of empathy because they can feel sorry
for you but they really don't care that
much so I think just knowing that I
understand who I'm gonna operate so I
don't put it like past them so for
example guys people like oh uh she
should care about how I feel but it's
about her first then you so I think on
some level understanding that I have
freedom because now I don't get mad or I
don't get upset okay that's how she is
cool I don't take it personal and I
think most guys they get mad because
they don't understand women and they're
like oh well I feel like it should be
this way no that's how women are deal
with it and you feel like that has
allowed you to do better with women
because now you know you're not let's
say rising to her her BS her emotions
her whatever it is I think every guy
should understand what he wants out of
things so for example the girl's going
to be dating me okay we're going where I
want to go not because what do you mean
do you mean like um like restaurant-wise
or just like life Direction so I'm the
guy planning the date okay I'm gonna
plan where we go what we do because for
one I'm paying for of course I asked her
on a date secondly I know the
environment under the landscape to have
a good experience I want to share that
with somebody else so I'm just gonna say
hey I find attractive let's go out she
says yes pick you up at eight meet me
here or or we'll meet at the spot and I
plan the whole day from there but then
at that point it's like something goes
be like oh well you know what I want to
go here well that changes the whole
dynamic because now it's like well uh
you want to change the day you want to
date yourself no so I think as a man you
should know from start to finish what
you want to do what you're about so can
you explain that to me a bit more
because
um I find and we'll get into this the
women on um your show a little confusing
to me I feel like they're not the the
typical women I think they're an extreme
type of woman so we'll get into that but
when you say okay I say we're going here
and she's like no I want to go there
what is she what is she um saying no to
is it like oh I'd rather go to a
different restaurant or I'd rather do a
different activity for example like say
you're like oh we're going kayaking and
she's like no I want to go for dinner
you know what I mean so yeah what's
what's the what's the difference it
could be both but I think just as a
general rule I would say if you're
planning the date you set the tone and
she wants to change that that's fine but
the first encounter I'm doing it my way
because once again I ask you on a date
you're gonna ask me on a date so if I'm
playing things from the from the get-go
hey you know what that's a cool
suggestion but we'll go here for now and
she says no cool part ways is what it is
but I think as a man you said the tune
from the very beginning and obviously
ticker I wanted to I want to say
thoughts into consideration and
eventually you know what we'll go there
eventually the beginning we're going
where I want want to go and I say I'm
going there anyway you're a plus one
yeah like if she's allergic to seafood
and you say let's go to seafood
restaurant obviously you're not gonna
force her to go to a seafood restaurant
yeah yeah you gotta have some level of
like I want to say respect there but at
the same time as a man you lead I want
to say interactions in it from there you
plan to date so what's the problem with
that why would why would a woman have a
problem with that you'd be surprised I
think there we go I think that they a
well for one it doesn't like you like
that she's not really that interested
into you yes either free food or a good
time but you understand but I think as a
guy you need to be aware so that you
don't fall into that trap you know yeah
okay and does that happen often a lot to
me I'm just saying in general no but in
general because this is something that
I've heard on um the podcast as well and
I've I hear a lot in like the manosphere
space that women would just are happy to
go out with men that they're not
interested in just to get a free meal
that to me is like the most insane thing
in the world it happens I think women
just want a fun experience you know I
mean like there's someone that says
girls will just want to have fun yeah
sure because once again I can get free
food
and get a club club set up for me free
drinks I can get a trip or a tour
somewhere I can get like a experience
for free why not and imagine this like I
want to say some girls have multiple
options which means they have a guy that
tasting oil for food some for drinks
some for just sex some for a trip some
for money pay the bills so they have
access to multiple guys so if you're not
aware of who you are as a man and you
just tolerate anything well you might be
using one of those categories which is
not what you want yeah that makes sense
and the women on your podcast I was
always like really taken back and I say
this every time I talk about a podcast
no the what I say is that I don't know
women like this like my friends I
promise you are actually really sweet
and if a man's like let's let's go for a
coffee date my friends will be like yeah
that would be really lovely thank you
you know whereas like now I'm hearing
there are these women getting like flown
out here flown out there and
I just sounds like a lot to me so from
from your opinion do you think that like
most women are like the women that you
see on your show
I'm gonna be honest
I would say this with all sense of
clarity and all sense of like
truthfulness
um no okay however
we take one from everywhere so not just
Miami that's from like New York Vegas
California UK Canada they're from
everywhere so on some level there's a
general I want to say idea where like
this is a common thought for a lot of
women not everyone of course like I said
before some women are different because
you can find government anywhere you
live doesn't matter in America yeah
Colombia it doesn't really matter
however I'm just gonna say as a general
like I want to say consensus
some women just offer them their own
needs and this means if I want to set up
a date for a woman and I mentioned
coffee or I mentioned like tea if she's
more you know what I wanna have fun I
have a good time I'll pass on that which
I understand because once again you
wanna have fun you want to enjoy life
however if she really likes you she
wants to spend time with you get to know
you better it doesn't matter where you
take her so I think that level of like I
want to say affectional like desire
leads to okay a good interaction versus
oh well you're not taking me here well I
don't want to go out then because you
know what you're so hot I'll take you
there it's like now you're under her
frame and it's like did you like you
probably not yeah no I think that's a
really good way to look at it um I'd
happily do nothing with someone that I
thought was amazing so I know girls that
would literally walk in a park yeah just
talk okay they actually like versus like
go on a expensive dinner or go to the
club and pop bottles like
you can't really bond with somebody over
these things unless you're actually into
them so yeah exactly and you know fresh
and fit is really dedicated to improving
men so what would you say the biggest
problem with men is today in 2023
I think men's biggest problem is
understanding that like in this life
you want to get what you work for yeah
and I think people want things like a
microwave mentality thick and easy right
now and for example guys want to get
girls but it's a whole process to get
girls because you can get a girl now but
can you retain her unless you gotta go
being broke your the child whatever
Tyrone she probably won't stay so my
thing is like a guy needs to level up
all areas of Life Fitness mindset money
status and if you're really good about
it I want to say social like awareness
because guys will go on dates and they
like Miss some cues they don't
understand how women really interact or
for example people in general which I
think is a big part of networking
reading people from the very beginning
and I think mastering everything in
totality will give you success however
it takes time even me myself like I just
gone to the gym maybe two months ago
because I was focused on success become
a certain level of certain status and
financially I'm already set for life but
Fitness was not my you know my concern
so I think on some level you have to
understand that we have to work on
everything but made that priority
and you said um sometimes like men Miss
cues with women I'm really curious what
kind of cues are men missing that women
are giving prime example so let's say
you're on a date with a chick right
she's feeling you she's feeling the mood
you took it to multiple spots she's
vibing with you she's like wow this
guy's attractive and she was rich she's
ready to go she's like you know what
you know what I'm tired like we should
get out of here you're like no let's
stay
bro she's ready to go right now why
waste time and then she's like oh she's
not answering me I gotta work in the
morning I'm just gonna go home so he
missed our opportunity because he can
read the cues or another example is
she's on a date with you she's on her
phone
it's boring
ah you know what my friend just called
me I got a dip oh she likes me but she's
she has to go because she your friend
her friend called her no no she didn't
like it all and she's playing with you
so it's like since her accused you can
become a woman's actual true feelings
but I feel people
maybe they listen to what they say but
not what they do so I think that's
another red flag because if you're a guy
out there you need to know because
assuming money you're successful you're
gonna get played yeah you got to be
aware that is so interesting so okay I
want to just like get into that a little
bit so
um you said that if a woman's if a
woman's friend calls in and she's oh I
gotta go I'm busy and a man genuinely
thinks she's busy she's obviously not so
women will always make time for a man
that they that they want to make time
for
listen I know girls that would drive
from Orlando yeah from Miami just to see
guys I don't go try to travel across
from like UK to Miami to see people it's
it's more like if she really wants to
make it happen so when a girl says to
you oh my friend called me I gotta go
she probably had planned out from way
before yeah if the guy sucks just call
me and it's like I get it because some
guy's weird but like yeah you know she's
not into you so read this read the cues
so yeah women will do absolutely
anything just to be with someone they
want to be with so I'm curious is the
same Truth for men or is it or can a man
genuinely just be really busy and need
to sort out his life and his stuff and
then when he's ready he'll go back to
the woman that he likes I would say most
men they'll do whatever for women
because they're either the desire is so
strong or they're really thirsty which
is which is fine
but amount of value does understand you
know what's what's important which like
his priorities we'll put business first
then his part is his woman so I think on
some level he'll handle the business
first because that's taken care of
because once again if that's not working
properly then we're probably not going
to work either because once again can't
pay the bills I can't maintain our you
know our relationship I can't maintain
our lifestyle what's the point once
that's met all right baby what's up
where you want to go what you want to do
let's let's hang out your priority now
yeah I think that's difficult for a lot
of women to to understand that male
mentality because as we said yeah like I
I will make time for someone that I that
I really like but it's very difficult
for a woman I think to just sit there
and be like oh you know he has to deal
with this and he has to deal with that
and then he'll come and get me here's
the other other uh end of it so let's
say right I spent all day with you I was
so right and I'm like okay give what you
want you want to spend time with me go
to movies cuddle hold hands get dinner
that's nice you know eat out you know
travel but I think worked work right so
what happens is in that instance you're
happy in the moment but then light bill
goes out yeah trips anymore uh you know
you can't go on dinner dates like you
used to things start slowing down
because once again his priorities have
shifted he's going to focus on what's
important and then you lose interest so
inevitably I just spent all that time
energy giving what you want really you
didn't know what you wanted because too
much time with somebody especially when
you're not focused on what's important
can be really from your path and as well
let's flip on another side let's say I
say you know what work is a priority I
work from like 8 A.M to let's say
regular time for most people five five
PM but when that's done your priority so
you might miss me or get upset during
the day if you see me the experience is
worth it so I think on some level as a
man you have to have that restraint
where you know what okay what's
important what's the priority I myself
had the issue because I'll go on three
days a day and that's bad because I'm
focused on work and then I lose my focus
and I lose everything so I think as a
man which most important business first
you can win and how did you learn all of
this did you learn it before fresher fit
did you learn it during fresh and fair
like at what point did the penny drop on
how women
um on female psychology and how to win a
woman over so I learned it before and
I'll say this because
um my past was very shaky I want to say
shaky I mean I mean very many mistakes
so
I'll give you another example I married
a single mother oh and it's not it's not
a bad thing how old are you if you don't
mind me asking I'm 30 now 30. yeah yeah
and back then I thought I knew what I
was doing because I was like oh yeah you
know I'm the guy you know I get girls
whatever but I didn't understand what it
meant to be in a relationship and I I
thought you know what okay this is
somebody that's ready they're willing to
do whatever I want but there's a kid
there as well and that means that to be
a stepdad and I was like 23 back then
22. I didn't know what that really meant
so that was a mistake I made and uh
luckily and did you know passively
nothing major happened we parted ways
good to go and then you know I would
date girls and I'll make certain
mistakes like for example I would
actually like do way more than I needed
to do to make things happen and I think
just being in those experiences I
learned okay you know what less is more
mine's book what I'm going to do with
less it's a funny title well kind of
controversial title but it means do
what's required and more you do can be
seen as RB is against you so I think
personally speaking as a guy
you don't know what you need to do and
not do too much so yeah no I find that
so interesting and yeah Myron Myron
definitely has a lot of valid points I
think for sure he also told me actually
um that when you met he liked that you
were good with girls that's what he said
to me so I'm curious what does that mean
to be good with girls so guys I don't
talk a lot about my escapades because
Athena's private should be private I'll
give you one major key here to get one
of your dreams it's called active
listening so this means we're
compensating right for the most part
I've been on your eyes for the whole
time I've really shifted I'm focused I'm
understanding what you're saying take an
in and kind of like give you answers
back so I think for most people they go
on dates especially guys they'll be like
oh yeah she's hot look at our titties
looking at her face but normally listen
to what she's saying and I think you can
actively listen to somebody and give
them like actual good answers back and
listen to what they're saying they can
get into conversation and the vibe is
there because most people they get into
a conversation oh yeah yeah cool all
right let me let me talk now versus what
is she really saying what does she mean
what is she about that goes a long way
yeah I keep hearing that actually
because I interview a lot of men and you
know I ask them their their advice to
other men on dating and they say make
her sell herself to you yeah pretty much
all right unless you're on a date and
guys focus on you solely people walking
around cars going back yeah that's so
hard like it's like damn he's focused on
me this much like he's into me this is
amazing that's nice no that's nice
that's true that's true
um so throughout you know the the last
few years doing fresh and fit if you
could pinpoint one issue with Modern Men
what would you say it is
oh man there's so many issues okay give
me three then three of the biggest
issues in one and then uh I would say
one not believing yourself
because especially in today's society
movies there's the agenda being pushed
there's a war on masculine as you guys
know uh entity talks about a lot where
guys are like seeing what's in the the
world for example of you know literature
of media and yeah don't be masculine
just be docile don't be too aggressive
don't actually go after what you want
just go to school get a job I think that
whole mentality itself makes men docile
I'm not really Achievers and that's bad
because once again it spreads like
wildfire you know most people I know are
happy living living or working a regular
job living regular life and I'm like
okay that's cool and all but like what
about your family what about people you
care about and secondly I would say is
like men's like actual care hygiene
because I think hygiene did you say
that's interesting because most guys I
think they just wake up maybe shower if
they want to or not I don't know and
then they just like go about their day
you're gonna do it it's like oh you
smell or you're like oh like it's not
good so I think on some level hygiene is
very important for guys and then in that
priority and three I would say another
issue that guys I was like they think
that the world I want to say will get
them whatever they want and you have to
work for it and like I said earlier like
if you don't work for it how you're
gonna achieve it as a man that burn of
performance is on you at all times so so
you mentioned Andre Tate and that's
funny because he actually just got
released today from news great news
listen I will say this I don't know any
girl on internet the more advocate of
Andrew than you if you showed mad love
when everyone hit it on him you showed
true logic and passion I think most
people they get scared because oh I'm
gonna get about last time I get attacked
but you didn't care you were Fearless so
that's powerful if you shout out to you
oh I appreciate that thank you so much
it was actually really stressful I'm not
gonna lie and when Andrew got out of
jail I told him I was like that was
really stressful
um so much hate
so much hate actually curious because I
think I heard the story before but can
you refresh me hug me Andrew my friend
boyfriend at the time
um we were together in Romania and we
all went out for dinner and and we met
everyone thinks I was like you know
partying but I'm like no I was with a
really nice man and we all met and yeah
they invited us over and then I think we
just kept in contact because like I
think he thought it was funny that I was
so into crypto I don't know I think he
thought that was funny so we kept in
contact and yeah but you've you've met
him quite um quite a few times so what's
your experience being with Andrew
um were you surprised when the
allegations came
yes because I know Andrew quite quite
well because back and forth we've seen
each other multiple times been in his
house for like a month however I would
say that with Andrew he's very sincere
and very transparent so if anything was
going to be I want to say done like that
would have seen it in live in color but
we didn't and then secondly there's
footage of everything in the house being
shown on the camera so he said he has
like footage everywhere of cameras in
each room so you would see or have some
type of like evidence of him doing these
things but there's none why is that they
didn't show the footage so I think this
is all some bull crap or some like sign
up against Andrew once again he didn't
do anything wrong I believe and I think
for the most part over time people will
see that as well because we talk about
um you know this agenda and this war on
masculinity so how intentional would you
think that war is and what what is
Andrew come into it like why are they
coming off to him so Andrew has
influence when influence comes power so
I can say as someone influence go go
vote for this person and my audience
they believe in me that trust me they'll
go vote for that person so imagine I can
swim election or sway people's mindset
or I want to say lifestyle but from what
I say so without power comes
responsibility and the part is that b at
the very top are like hey you know what
it's not what our agenda get him out of
here so I think on some level like they
see him as a threat to their I want to
say full-time agenda and even though
it's the truth people don't want to hear
the truth because the truth will say
you're free which means if people are
free from you know their oppression or
what's they're being held against then
they can think for themselves and make
logical choices at least to them being
free from The Tyranny itself but what
Andrea's doing is telling people to
um that depression isn't real which I
think is a really empowering mind sex it
means it doesn't have a hold over you um
you know he talks about how to make
money fast um how to be a better man how
to get more women I mean how to live a
more fulfilling life as a man what's the
problem with that why can't he why can't
he say that I think Andrew's like a
superhero because when people look up to
obviously Batman you know Thor Superman
and then fictional characters him being
real and you can see tangibly his assets
lifestyle his physique him as a man it's
inspiring because no one I know has that
level of influence on people especially
young kids so I think that is a danger
to what they're planning and again
Andrew speaks the truth however the
truth is not I want to say rewarded in
these times
do you ever feel any concern that some
kind of like similar allegations could
come against you and the reason I ask is
because I'm noticing that men who become
extremely successful and make a lot of
money are then surrounded by a lot of
women like you are and then suddenly
allegations come out of nowhere and and
also somebody who I interviewed and I'm
not going to mention their name and I
think he's a really good guy genuinely
I'm so humble so respectful somebody had
texted me about him saying be careful I
heard allegations and I'm like this is
just more rubbish because this man is so
successful so are you ever concerned
that something like that could happen
against you or anyone around you Myron
or anything like that I think any guy
especially in our space or for example
given the truth or revealing certain
things is a target so nobody's safe not
myself however I'll say this Yoshi
receipts so yeah more people
to go through life they just have
experiences and they don't really take
in receipts I have everything texts
phone calls I have like camera footage
in my room I have everything right so if
anything comes up oh you want to play
these games here's the proof no I didn't
do anything what kind of receipts I need
details fresh let's just say I record
everything okay here's everything they
know they've been recorded I'm just
saying everything that needs to be for
example gonna come into my apartment you
know me being out with them in public
like I do a vid because once again it's
only their word against my word yes but
if it's video proof then okay cool we
can go off for that as well I think for
most men if you're of a certain status
in certain power you are a Target
because once again if you're not
following the agenda or what they want
get them out of here how do you do it
call them a grapes call him a trafficker
all these things because oh you're
attacking women you're attacking uh
people you're hurting your incentive
balance get them out of here yeah I
think on some level
you need to be aware and be cautious
because you're a Target as well any guy
that is so fascinating I think the fact
that you record everything just shows
how serious this is and and how being a
man of value and having money and being
successful makes you a Target and you're
not the only one I I also know other
people who will actually record a woman
consenting before anything happens later
well you have to what do you mean no I I
fully get that because because if you've
seen the women on your show they're
crazy as if you if you hurt her feelings
she might be like I didn't consent to
what happened next but if you have that
consent on camera I don't know I'm a
nice guy man that's what you mean that
is nice I know but honestly like okay I
get that part because that's that's good
yes I really understand that but I think
you can do it in more in direct ways for
example you can do a text message saying
hey you go home safe we had a great time
together oh yes it was a great time oh I
see confirm so I'm doing it but
indirectly because I I think if you do
that it's kind of it might ruin the mood
a little bit but I get it it works
because some people have to have that
like right there in writing so but again
I always think that with women you have
a good experience back and forth both
parties and that direction I think it's
for example people say oh I want to just
one undone I think it's better to have
multiple interactions multiple
experiences because what's the point of
Smashing dipping I think that's a little
bit kind of like on some level winning a
certain point it's kind of like not
worth it to me what are you looking for
in a woman
so uh I'm looking for
great experiences I'm looking for
someone that's going to be like able to
follow the program which means my
lifestyle I'm about understand time as
well I can't always be with you doing
stuff and I think on some level
um if you're looking for things like
that up front you don't find it versus
you're focus on what you need to focus
on become your weight however you need
to be aware when it's in your face so I
know guys that phone great women right
and as a result they were focused on
their passion purpose but they were so
focused that they couldn't see that was
a good woman and then they either
treated her they didn't take her
seriously and like damn like she was
stalling it I messed it up so I think
just being aware and so you know okay
these are some good examples of good
traits or good like habits or good you
know uh good mindset for this person
that matches my lifestyle give it a
chance see where it goes
that's really good that's a really good
point I'm gonna use that when I get out
into into the real world I'm gonna I'm
gonna use that and yeah I'm gonna use it
in my own smart ways what am I looking
for oh man it's very complicated fresh
oh man I'm looking for okay so I I'm
down with the program right like you
lead I'm ready to switch my brain off
it's all you whatever you say I'm down
with the program right but it's very
difficult because I want to find a man
that's um you know smarter than me more
intelligent than me and somebody who I
can trust fully that he will lead me and
the children to
um a a prosperous life basically
question for you yeah are you
comfortable with the man
every now and then stepping out
I don't know we'll have to see I don't
know I mean of course no ideally no
um and that I have met a lot of men who
are of that value that will be faithful
to one woman
um I I have met that I don't know I
don't know we'll see let me let me meet
the man first and and see but I I also
think you know if like
I provide him with everything that he
needs then hopefully he you know it's
enough he's satiated it's enough I don't
know I just it's funny because I don't
think women understand like yeah for the
most part you can't really satisfy a man
all the way you can obviously make
things better easier but satisfy him in
totality he's gonna want stranger every
now and then it's good to know you know
I'm not you know I don't think he's an
evil person for wanting that you know I
hear that a lot so we will see I have to
figure that out you know I will say this
so being in this environment for so long
and having these like interactions of a
woman and obviously doing that what I
just said earlier
you understand that like it does hurt
the woman on some level because she
wants you to be only for her and I think
as a as a guy
you wear the odds all right you know
what I've done this for so long x amount
of times I understand what it does and I
care about my girl so much
I might have to like say you know what
okay don't want to keep doing this I
don't want to keep hurting her what's
the the level of like I want to say
respect her and I think as a man you
commit that touch for yourself but God's
gonna do what I do anyway so I think if
you're aware of it it's better I think
that's like the best thing anyone's ever
said on my podcast to be honest okay
because everyone's so black and white
about things but that is really true as
well you know if you like you okay so a
man might need a strange a stranger once
in a while or whatever as you put it but
ultimately like that's gonna hurt your
woman and if she's a really good woman
and she's doing everything for you she's
the best mother she's a beautiful wife
she's keeping herself looking good you
know she respects you honors you she's
doing everything and you're gonna do
that and just like hurt her I feel like
love is is a sacrifice like
to love someone is a sacrifice whether
it's so whether it's like becoming a
mother you sacrifice your body whether
it's becoming a husband maybe you have
to sacrifice that that one little thing
which is not sleeping with random
strangers I don't know each to their own
but I definitely think like to make
something work any relationship somebody
does have to sacrifice something so I've
seen two examples in my life where it's
worked very well I have a family member
who lives up north in Saint Augustine
he's a big portfolio real estate it's
very successful within a huge like
property
his girlfriend lives down the street
they don't they don't live in the same
house right but they meet with each
other go to eat go to the beach or
travel they live in separate houses
right then they're not married but they
have an understanding where like their
long-term Partners so they have that
relationship they're together but
they're not on paper married yeah then
I've seen
someone has been married to like my
grandparents right right for like six to
seven years very successful very um good
for the family they raised me my mom
everybody but
I can see where like them being together
in the same house for so long they have
like a level of bitterness level of like
you know resentment and it never goes
away so there's always bickering and
back and forth and I think it worked but
just having the space to miss each other
or to have the space to like do your own
thing yeah gives you more of a freedom
and I think love is freedom because it's
gonna let somebody go and do what they
need to do to come back to you
that to me that's love because you
understand what it is and you don't take
it personal obviously it's going to hurt
you yeah but love is freedom yeah if I
love you you know what you need to go
learn yourself for yourself what this
means or what it can do to you if you
come back that's love that's a really
interesting point
um because I think that um you know
there's this idea in this red pilled
space that like a woman shouldn't do
anything she should just be there like
praying and waiting for her amazing man
to come home right doing nothing all day
um which I can understand you know um
but I have met people who I've met other
guys who've said to me they want a woman
to be busy and to have a life and to do
stuff and that really blew my mind
because that's kind of what you're
saying really because it's like if a
woman has her life and a man has his
life whether or not they live together
but they they have their own something
which they love outside of each other
then that allows them to have space and
then come back to each other I agree
kind of so let me explain because I
think she should focus on her man's yes
dreams and passions first because that's
going to set the tone or like I want to
say the stable relationship of you know
what this are money coming in together
you're being taken care of cool then
after that set and that's in place you
know what maybe we're set up we're good
to go you got a passion you want to do
go ahead and do it yeah that's a good
way to put it because if it's two
careers two different like positive two
different Dreams yeah clash and then oh
sorry I'm doing this or I need you here
but you can't show up it's like no no so
then what are we doing yeah yeah like if
he needs her to show up and she's like
sorry I've got work no honey this isn't
gonna work you need to be in it you need
to be here yeah it's it's tough out of
that fresh let me tell you
um you already know so um what's what's
your opinion on um a high Valley man
this term that's just floating around
the internet that nobody can stand
anymore what is a high value man I'm not
gonna lie that Thomas played out that's
what I'm saying I'm definitely tired of
hearing that term I think um
we've over the word yeah
and context is it's it's good for a
placeholder term but I think um we're
past that now I think most people
have their own level of like what value
means to them so I would say high value
for what it used to be is more of a guy
that's like on his purpose he has the
network people that he that can help him
or he can help them and he's on some
level of the status where he can
influence people to either do good or do
bad I think
for most people an example of high
status would be our high value would be
Entertain You know
um or for example Myron gains yeah or
for example anyone you can see as like a
leader or as a superhero in your own
eyes I would say could be considered
high value and what's the perfect woman
in your eyes
yeah oh thanks that's good I can tell by
the way you're looking at me um I'm not
perfect are you kidding okay
um so perfect okay
is there a perfect woman I would think
so I think for you which means she fits
your lifestyle because I came in a girl
today that's good for me but not good
for like your brother because again my
lifestyle is going to be what I need her
to do for me or he might need something
completely different you probably have
the same let me you probably yeah I can
see possibly I'm just saying I don't
know each person's lifestyle wants so
whatever she can be to that man perfect
for him how can a woman retain a man
simple
follows program
don't be a b word don't be a wall oh
don't be what okay yeah yeah be feminine
be feminine because I think the word be
feminine sorry the term be feminine is
kind of
misplayed too because on some level like
this means you want to be feminine yes
so don't force it like oh I gotta be
feminine no like okay do you like the
guy you into the guy
naturally you're going to want to be
feminine yeah I mean because it could be
like oh be feminine
you should pretend for a little bit no
[__] it comes out Chris is like okay
this guy actually want to be with he's
that guy that I want to surf under or
actually be with yeah all right you know
what I don't even mess this up at all
honestly perfect I won't mess up I'm
focused and now I said thirdly um on
some level understanding like if you are
hung around and being like on the
streets that's cool for you right in the
moment but if the guy ever finds it or
sees patterns or habits you know this
lifestyle I might turn them off so keep
that in mind whenever you're dating
because you don't see it maybe in the
short term in the long term it can
affect you and mess up your future would
uh promise you man and um you said
earlier that you prefer white women to
get a lot of hate for that I imagine
that's a whole nightmare ah
I think I've ever told a story let's
hear it why does why I had this
preference now
should I give it to you yeah I'll give
it to you so as I said before I'm from
Barbados right and uh obviously speaking
the majority of people that are women
there are black
which is fine you know I love flower men
black queens you could have had that in
there but I feel like I've dated quite a
few and I was like cool I want you
something different so one day I was on
the beach with some friends uh I could
be should be exact it's like on the
tourist area in Barbados and um you know
I met these girls from UK actually right
we talked a little bit were they white
they're white okay all right I don't
know white is right what is right upside
down no but um so closing travel so then
uh we spoke a little bit it was super
cool super down on Earth I was like oh
this is different because you know
typical like they could do what I want
no no is that how it's like in Barbados
well it's not like that but it's kind of
like it's still kind of a bit
quite easily especially if you like
pissed them off
I'll tell you this don't get any
Caribbean woman mad that's a that
sentence okay no but um and then
I'm a Canadian woman you know I met
American woman and it was kind of like
I would say a different take on things
and more relaxed and then I got my first
white girl from Canada shout out to
Vancouver and
um I was just like
this experience is like fun I I'm more
relaxed and more chill it's just overall
this is a better I want to say
environment for me yeah and then I saw
patterns were like damn this is like a
lot of like same type of women how the
same type of pattern no I understand
that women can't be like black women can
be bad or good I'm just saying and not
in that setting I saw where like it's
different I want to see lights are
different like women were more what I
wanted to be around so and you get a lot
of backlash for that though
I mean I see it on the podcast there's
one guy I don't know I can't remember
his name but he's on your podcast and he
just like says he just drags black women
and it just and then it just gets really
I think one woman got really like
physical with him yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um I know what you mean but I I don't
see his name yeah I can't remember the
name to be honest but I I would say this
right there's I want to say
natural biases or natural preferences
yeah there are stereotypes
and sometimes they're true well not
everyone's like that yeah of course like
my mom my sister you know they're black
they're not the typical
American black woman but they're
American and same thing with white girls
some of them are you know not as nice to
some of them are rude oh some of them
are terrible the white guys especially
the ones from the UK that's why I asked
yes
is that a birth that's a British time
yeah yeah it is yeah so No One's Gonna
Be Perfect or the same I'm just saying
generally what I've seen is that like
for me that works better for my
lifestyle okay that makes sense there's
like a
a gem for the podcast yeah birth control
who's on birth control my girls are they
the most part oh okay so like once again
like you know I'm Free Willy up in that
I see but once again but you know how
bad birth control is like you don't want
to marry a woman that's on birth control
by the way like do you know about this
tell me you don't know about the birth
control thing they get chubby they get
worse no birth control is bad because it
like yeah it just it just suppresses a
woman's real personality and it
suppresses her real appetite her real
desire for a man and actually a woman
who's on the pill for an extended period
of time will prefer a more beta soft
kind of man just because of where where
in the cycle it like holds her basically
the hormones that it gives her and so
then she comes off the pill say so sorry
so say the woman marries this beta man
because she loves him and she's been on
the pill they get married she comes off
the pill to have children and then her
preferences change and then she wants
like the Tarzan you know the man the bad
boy and now they've got a problem so
these poor men are marrying these women
and then these women don't want them
anymore all because of birth control it
just messes women up completely and then
it like it gives them like depression
and anxiety and then they start taking
antidepressants and then like she just
becomes like a cocktail of of of of uh
you know hormones and ssris and and all
this stuff
I've never heard that tape before really
that's crazy yeah don't marry a woman
that's being on the pill for an extended
period of time well to be honest though
uh that's a good take I just personally
don't want to get married again
fair enough oh yeah so that's yeah and
you don't be having children with women
you don't want to be having children
with so that's smart I'm in it for a fun
experience and a fun time and now I'm
out okay so you say you don't want to
get married
um okay uh well no that could change in
the future I'm just saying right you're
only 30. yeah yeah right now I'm I'm
like nah I did it before it's cool you
know right now okay so I have several
questions okay my first question is
sorry you managing okay so my first
question is um yeah uh
so you so you'd get married or not would
you or would you not get married one day
are you against the institution of
marriage like some people basically well
the laws I'd say are not immense saver
right so if I was ever to do it it'd be
like I'll say the country or maybe by a
church only you know okay and I wouldn't
not want to live
all the way with that person because
once again it's common law marriage so
certain things will put you in that
category of being married so to speak
under the law I want to be upset of that
paradigm and would you be monogamous
one day are we done yet would you mean
monogamous Monday it's a nice watch
we'll talk about that in a sec oh
oh I think personally speaking you asked
me the same question basically yeah I
could do it yeah and I can do it
but time will tell but time will tell I
get that a lot of men change yeah a lot
of men change from um early 30s yeah I
wanted to say something
of a stance or have a stance right now
yeah but I understand it like it may not
be forever so I'm always saying you know
what okay right now I think this way for
the future it might change so can I give
you a perspective which I see in Miami
sure so I agree with basically
everything that you guys say you know um
and I I'm very intellectually honest so
I can look at myself and I can I can see
the kind of man I'm attracted to and I'm
like okay well you know I'm cleaning not
going for the betas am I you know so
okay I'm gonna have to deal with that
then but there's something that I see in
Miami and I think it's really sad so I
can be at a bar with a girlfriend or be
at dinner with a girlfriend
um and there's a bar there and I always
see an old man okay I always see an old
lonely man probably in his like
60s you know 70s he's got money good for
him sugar daddy but he's not got a
partner and he's hitting on all these
women in their 20s and these women like
are so uninterested and I did speak to
one guy he I don't know how old he was
but he kind of annoyed me he was
probably like late 60s and he was trying
to like start a conversation with me the
only way he could like get me to respond
was by like he tried loads of different
things and so then he went down the
politics route and I'm very opinionated
and political so I was like wow so I
responded with that's not true you know
like red flag good thing to note don't
ever
bring politics with a girl no no I think
it's a good thing because if a man if a
man is a liberal we're not getting on so
I want to know straight away like did
you take the magic medicine like did you
believe in the flu and I need to know
it's good for you but not for him oh
yeah yeah for him right so he brings it
up right and so I end up hearing about
his life story and he basically told me
that um he had he met a lot of great
women throughout his life you know he
stayed in the nicest hotels or the
fanciest restaurants but um he messed it
up along the way and you know he there
was one good woman that he didn't take
seriously and and now you know he's in
his 60s 70s with a broken leg limping
around Miami and no woman wants him even
though he's got money so my point is
just like I always tell men just just be
careful I know you think you have all
the time in the world because you have
more time than women do for sure you
have like decades on us a hundred
percent just be careful because like you
that like you know there is an expiry
date and like you don't want to be doing
that alone yeah I would say the hunt
never ends when you're not lifestyle
because there's always like new girls
coming in yeah it's a rotation happening
so you know you don't always have like
that like on a security of like okay
she's gonna be here she's gonna be here
so that I can understand from your point
of view from that story that makes sense
however what I will say is like if
you're good enough for example you you
know the game you're actually like that
guy you have some like Mains like like
solid girls are like no matter what
happens she's rocking with you because
you're that guy to her so I say if you
got that you're good if you don't have
that then it's kind of like are you
playing the field you got some here
today some tomorrow not tomorrow it's
like you're gambling because you're
right sometimes time is gonna run out
because yeah you're not gonna be that
guy anymore yeah no exactly and I'm
curious do you think that the whole red
pill thing ever goes too far
it's a setup right
um I
don't
play into that okay just because like
okay I understand and I appreciate the
space it's amazing space but I think
it is very black and white and at the
same time the truth is gonna set you
free and that is that is the truth
but there's a space between there that's
gray that we don't really talk about so
I think on some level you need to
understand what it is and be a part of
it but understand there's more to that
than just the black and white that's
what I would say okay and you have a
nice watch I want to ask you about that
yes it's very nice this is the AP
skeleton I thought it was an AP I don't
know anything about watches but I'm like
a man Andrew Tate actually shout out to
him he's the button version of this
watch uh so walk into a room right who
watches like okay I see a AP there
regular aps-c Rolex but what is this
what is this and it's like either you
know or you don't know yeah and if you
know it's like wow good job bro or it's
like damn what is that so I think this
watch itself creates a lot of
conversation I like it because it's open
work but um yeah I was part of Andrew
what's up what's the what's the thing
with men in their watches I don't get it
because I don't wear any jewelry like I
wear like my earrings my grandma bought
me this that's it I'm done I don't even
want to watch I can see with someone
with some Van Cleef I don't even know
what that is what is that it's like the
the pedals like the gold pedals with the
black insides you know
you've seen it before like the bracelets
the chain is it like a flower yeah I
hate that really well it because
everyone has it I hate it I keep seeing
it everyone's wearing it I actually hate
it yeah okay well that's so funny no I
don't know I don't wear anything so
explain to you what is what is it with
men in there watches like for guys
is that the tip for networking as well
you wanna have things to start
conversations because most people they
walk into a room no one knows who you
are they don't even see you first says
okay you walk into a room okay he's
wearing it he's wearing this he's
wearing these shoes this pants he has
this type of like walk to him he has a
presence right so most people want to
talk to people that are on their level
or higher so I walk into a room I walk
with this watch if you know well that's
nice let's watch man what do you do for
a living so off rip I start a
conversation with somebody off my watch
alone or I'm like in a business meeting
and the guy's okay he's wearing a Rolex
like a regular date Day date all right
whatever oh he has AP or protect oh his
guy's on big business like okay let's
see what he's about so they'll come at
you a certain way based on what you're
wearing as well even with the car you
put you pull up the venue or a spot with
your car a nice lambor or a Rolls-Royce
it gives you a perception of who you are
as a person so that gives you a step in
the door I would say versus walking in
with nothing because then it's like uh
broke on some level you know so even
though I would say a lot of people I met
their successful multi-millionaires
billionaires they don't wear anything so
it just depends on that but first glance
perception if you have something nice
like a nice watch it will get you
conversation started so I always thought
like Rolex was like the watch until I
got to Miami and then like everyone's
doing watches and my brother's into
watches and now I'm like oh okay so it's
a Rolex like I could be so wrong right
now but it's a prolax the low end of
like high-end watches or am I just not
or am I just getting old so this is my
take on watches my category freshest
category watches from people I know in
different spaces different networks
different like environments this is my
Collective view on list of tier watches
right so number one I would say at the
very top is protect for League because
it's not that commonly uh worn if you're
gonna have a potentially you know class
or business or you're a level where like
you know what you're tired of being seen
with the Rolex or like the aps because
everyone has those right right then down
from that I would say is the AP mhm AP
is classic you know you can't go around
AP
um generally speaking you were AP you
have some status as well but it's not
like a tech right what does AP stand for
anything no more forget say again Auto
more pickets okay yeah and then uh I
would say under that would be like a
Rolex because once again I think it's a
good investment because everyone knows
about Rolex it's a time-tested piece
it's been here for generations to come
and um I think on some level you should
have one in Your Arsenal because that's
going to be the entry level or like the
standard and from the upgrade to a
different watch when you're ready
and then if you want to be flexing Paula
like I'm in your face with your Millie
but I think on some level it's kind of
to try hard sometimes but that's just me
though right how many watches do you
have that's your brother
we want to come in Gideon loves watches
and I only I only thought that was an AP
because of what my brother's showed me
because I go to all the watch shops with
him so you want to say bro yeah no no I
think so I I also like I said I really
really like watches um like like the
minute I saw you I said beautiful AP
Audemars PK but like I think you had a
really good what uh watch tag but I
would say
Rolex yes I agree is the third
the third greatest and luxury brand I
think you're right Patek is probably the
best and maybe AP is second but there
are certain Rolex pieces which push
Rolex back at the back at the top with
with ap you're right and Patek so like
for example so I've got a uh where's the
camera so I have a Daytona it's a steel
Daytona on right so that's quite an
in-demand piece but then you get to the
real real high end where you have like
rainbow Daytona and certain Platinum uh
daytonas with like Arabic dials and I
think those go to the back at the top
with the um with the patex yeah you're
right you know and even some Paul Newman
daytonas
um and some old submariners references
with like Steve McQueen like more the
Vintage pieces you're talking about like
I want to see unique pieces so you're
right yeah you are right on that sense
I'm talking about generally though no no
that's also true yeah generally yeah
like the um the Patek Nautilus or the
yeah of course like they're they command
higher prices and and they're even
harder to get but like I think certain
Rolex pieces even like daytonas now
because of the whole Paul Newman thing
um yeah I would say they're up there
with Patek that's just my view because a
lot of people you get that watch like
for example the special daytonas like
it's hard to get yeah
like who are you how'd you get this
watch exactly yeah yeah like so many
people yeah yeah so many people ask me
all the time about my Daytona like oh
how did you I told you when I first saw
you nice watch man yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know it's the first thing he said I
was like hey I feel I was like and I saw
his watch Cars like watch guys no you
know I was like I appreciate that um but
yeah I think Rolex is definitely up
there with certain pieces but I think
you also made a good point the the whole
Rolex datejust that also is that's
definitely low tip kind of Play-Doh it's
played out it's low tier I mean you
might even compare it to like Omega uh
which is which some people won't like
yeah I'm not really into the whole day
chats they just
that's a special type of like category
because those people that who blows that
think are a certain class yeah I won't
rank it as like a what you want to have
every day I could be wrong with it yeah
who who blows interesting because uh
Hublot as they call it that's it like
that they they yeah it hasn't got a good
name at all it's got it because they
they they came into the watch market so
quickly and like the the 80s and just
exploded and everyone was like okay in
order to be like you know high-end
classy luxury that's the watch you have
to get and it kind of got a really bad
name in that regard and people just
don't like them anymore yeah Hublot and
that's what I fear Richard Mille will go
I think rashan I think they'll go down
that end yeah because once yeah I think
they look amazing but it just like to me
it's kind of try hard and it's kind of
like pushing me okay look at me Richard
Milly versus like you just wear it
subtle what what is that piece yeah AP
so I agree with that like the whole
Rashad Miller like they are beautiful
watches and there's this new Raphael
Nadal uh blue you know with the blue
yeah you know which one I mean it is
beautiful I think the rm350 I can't
remember but it's beautiful and I get it
but it is also like look at me I'm
trying too hard and that's the whole
purpose of it I think as well that is
one watch you can wear with no other
pieces originally that's all you gotta
wear yeah people know what time it is
okay this guy yeah big baller over here
it's so true because they're half a
million dollar watches but then if you
pull up with a data like I was a komodo
the other night with this girl and we're
just sitting at the bar waiting for our
table and then I see this guy he's got a
rainbow Daytona and I and I just had to
talk to him I was like I was like I like
that where did you get that and he goes
I picked up in Germany you're compelled
to start work conversation yeah I heard
you say that that's where things like
start from the conversation yeah oh bro
what do you do for a living oh I do
crypto I do for example real estate oh
really looking for a partner in this
space What do you do oh well just so you
know do that as well let's partner up
yeah you never know exactly no no it's
so true but yeah uh but yeah okay that's
the watch conversation yeah yeah no no
it's all good
thanks man yo there you go just learning
everything from Gideon and he teaches me
everything makes it yeah it makes it
impossible to you know whatever anyway
yeah he's great
um Okay so we've done the watches oh I
wanted to ask you um you know for people
who are really inspired by your story um
I'm particularly inspired you know
because she only came here seven years
ago what would you say some of the best
ways are to make money online right now
in 2023. so right now uh anything
online's gonna make money because once
again you don't have to be physically
there you can be online with your
presence or for example have automated I
think for example e-commerce
um you could do
ah affiliate marketing you can do as
well you can do as well
um what else can you do Amazon as well
you can do YouTube Twitch streaming is
good as well I think for the most part
try different things and then see what
works for you because for me I tried
multiple things I said all these things
I mentioned before I tried and I did
okay with them but I wasn't really like
successful yeah and I think give it six
months to like maybe like a gear Max and
it's you know what this is from here is
not so you're gonna know by doing it and
let's say you don't know against the
environments where people are about
doing those same activities or
Elementary enough space learn from the
mentor okay you know what I'll give my
best let's see what takes me and if it
doesn't work cool you know what I'll
show them something different so getting
to that space learning the environment
actually doing it you know what you can
fill out if it works for you or not and
for how long do you think the online
thing is gonna work you know do you
think you know the Market's already
saturated or do you think that people
have got another five years to really
break into it and in 10 years you know
everyone's gonna be on to the next grift
as they say I think it's gonna still
have relevancy but with AI and how
things are going
um you can kind of automate most things
nowadays and more businesses yeah so
most young guys are getting into like
chat gbt you know AI um tools so on some
level I think the older generation of
like online money is gonna have to
surrender or cave into the AI generation
so yeah would it be forever no but with
the Advent of AI I think is going to be
pretty like concrete who's gonna be on
top yeah no absolutely and what are you
working on right now like what are your
goals you know what do you what do you
want to do with fresh and fit are you
guys going to continue what are your
personal goals
so
for me right now I focus on my co
Network along with the podcast so I
mentioned earlier with the podcast I was
making a concern being successful we
cannot pop off making us hit a million
subscribers having us around the world
in conversations that's my main goal
that's complete you know invested some
money money saved up Mom taken care of
family good to go so all my goals have
been met car lifestyle girls family good
to go
so I got bored yeah I was like okay cool
what's next I was partying a little bit
going to too many Yachts you know doing
too much dumb stuff then I was like damn
like this is not me
what is wrong with me
so I had a phone call with a mentor of
mine he spoke for like an hour he was
like listen man I can see you're doing
well but I see what happened to you you
lost your purpose it's like damn you're
right I hit all my goals I had no other
for the goals to like work towards so I
was just doing whatever
then I was like okay what can I do to
actually like give back and actually
like have a I want to say value add to
people again and podcast is dope it's
already set up that's really good to go
fresh fit all the way never will stop
that but I was like what can I do
personally speaking on my end and I
create a seal Network which means these
group of guys here from all over the
world from UK Canada America but you
want to become better and as well they
want to learn Network people and add
value so I think Mr and that group give
me more purpose as well we just had a
Columbia trip as well I saw Mastermind
pretty dope everyone showed out had a
great time so I think having that
Brotherhood is supporting me on because
before I would just like be alone wolf
like I said earlier but it doesn't help
you because you don't have that like
accountability partner to tell you but
you're messing up so I think me doing
that I mean for filters my new purpose
and then for the podcast to be on
platform not be canceled that's my new
I'm not gonna get Council on the podcast
that's amazing some really really
amazing goals you know I want to say
something uh which is funny actually um
this whole like manosphere red pill
space whatever has such a Negative
um like has such a neg has such a
negative connotations online everybody
always thinks you guys are like
misogynistic and you're you hate women
and all this stuff and um what's funny
is I've now interviewed like most of
these people
and my experience has been really good
like I think every all of these people
that I've met are really well to do
people they speak well they're very
um they're very um on time they're
courteous they're polite and everything
like that and um you know I I did a show
with somebody who um was basically just
tearing the red pill space apart and
saying they're all clowns they're all
this and this individual that
interviewed me I found him to be
inappropriate he was making sexual jokes
he was um I personally found him like
creepy and offensive and it's like
you're criticizing the red pill men yeah
when they sit down on my podcast they
are polite they are courteous they are
respectful and I just found that so
interesting because obviously we've
never met but my My overall take from
this podcast I found you really polite
respectful informative you add a lot of
value entertaining like I think you're
great to be honest and yeah and and you
know it's just it's just funny to me
because these people say oh they're
they're all in cells they're they're
misogynists they're this they're that
and then I meet them and they are the
ones that make me uncomfortable they're
the ones as a woman I'm like I just felt
disrespected I felt that was distasteful
and I'm so upset that I just sat down
with you isn't that funny yeah it's also
people that have the most opinionated
takes on people they're doing the worst
and I'll just say this so a lot of
creators in this in the outside YouTube
space could have said our platforms
because oh you're helping them become
better but you're still like you know
degrading women my thing is like okay
what is the truth the truth tells people
in your face you may not like it but
it's telling you what's happening in
real time I think for most other
creators they're like you know what
let's pan it to what's gonna get us the
most views the most like likes the most
like comments and that doesn't always
lead to the truth and for us we
understand obviously dynamics of social
being social women you know lifestyle
business but we respect people yeah I
think that in a whole most people don't
do anymore just like you know what do
what I say or or if not you're a bad
person
yeah it's it's just so fascinating to me
because yeah you're all I think you're
great and it's the same with Andrew it's
like every time um I meet an Andrew Tate
fan in real life they come up to me and
they're so respectful polite well
behaved they never make me uncomfortable
um and so yeah all these all the haters
they're the creeps and they're the weird
ones so yeah white Knights those guys
they're like Pander to you know the
agenda listen man yeah give me some help
bro yeah that's why they say male
feminists are the most uh dangerous
people of all yeah well fresh it's been
such a pleasure um thank you so much for
coming on the show how can people follow
you and and follow everything that
you're doing so guys Monday Wednesday
and Friday fresh podcast tune into that
me Myron cover dating lifestyle business
and as well
how to be successful and guys for me
personally speaking you can watch my
Vlog Channel freshman CEO or join my
network we had to Value every single day
we want a special guests we just had on
Wes Watson and we're brought on
Microsoft 10 today as well and once
again guys go follow Layla and her
brother cool thanks so much for coming
on guys if you enjoyed this episode
please don't forget to hit the like
button and hit subscribe so you stay up
to date on all my latest videos